MICHAEL SILISKI: Hello everyone! My name is Michael Siliski.
I am primarily responsible for product management for apps and games on Google Play.
Today I will be with Ellie Powers.
Give you a brief introduction on how to create better applications.
Make your app available
Excellent user experience
Well known
Quality is the cornerstone of mobile application business success
Users expect high quality applications
But in today's mobile applications
It’s not enough to just attract users to install your app, right?
You need to develop rich features
Create a great user experience
Let them love your application
You need to make users willing
Proactively recommend your app to friends
Also make users willing to spend in your app
According to what we have seen over the years
The better the user experience of the app
The more users are willing to spend money on it
The higher the star rating you get in the Google Play store
The more you earn
Therefore, it is definitely worth your time and energy.
To understand what users like about your app.
And problems encountered by users during use
And proactively manage user feedback
If you do this
In the long run, this kind of investment will make you
Get a return on business income
There are many criteria for evaluating application quality.
By observing the most successful apps on Google Play
we discover
Application features and quality of user experience
Mainly reflected in four aspects
First of all, these applications can pass various functions that users like.
Really meet user needs
Second, they are not only beautifully designed
And easy to use and users are happy to use
Third, these applications are very stable and reliable.
They won't crash
And it won’t consume a lot of traffic and power.
Fourth, these applications are quite creative.
They are built using the latest Android features
So stand out from the many applications
We need to consider applying these four aspects to
The entire life cycle of an application goes from design to development to the entire process of release.
I will invite our developer product manager
Tell everyone how to be in the life of your app
Use these four factors that determine the quality of your application
Ellie Powers with outstanding talent
ELLIE POWERS: Thank you, Michael.
Hello everyone, as Michael mentioned
We will introduce these three different stages one by one.
And explore how to improve quality
Let’s start with the design
Does anyone remember the lecture on Material Design last year?
If someone doesn't remember
Or we didn’t come last time today, we will review it quickly.
Then let's take a look at the developers.
Use of Material Design
Will also introduce several updates
Let everyone know what's new in the field of Material Design
Material Design is a design system
How to move the interface and interface style
And how to adapt to the user's touch operation is clearly defined
For more information on Material Design
Please visit developer.android.com/design
This is a very good place to start
Material Design has four principles
First, the appearance is tangible
The overall idea is
Application run
It should be the same as the real thing in reality.
Second, modeled on the design of printed matter
That is, the content should be eye-catching, vivid, and clear-cut.
You can use the look and feel provided by Material Design
Retouch as needed to reflect the brand characteristics of your app
Third, use meaningful actions
You can use actions in your app to get the user’s attention
And when the user switches from one screen of the application to another
Keep coherent
Fourth, adopt adaptive design
The focus of this principle is that you can create an adaptive layout.
Let users use their mobile phones, tablet TVs, Android Wear or Android Auto cars
Come to your app and have a familiar feeling
You can't let users switch to other types of devices each time.
Re-adapt to the design of your application
Now let's watch a short animation.
In the process of watching
See if you can find these four principles
[play video]
[play music]
[End of video playback]
In the past year and a half
We have witnessed
Android developers like everyone are starting to use Material Design
Developed a large number of creative applications
Make your app more beautiful
Also easier to use
If you are interested, you can visit the URL here.
Watch some of the best apps using Material Design
And get inspiration to perfect your app
Next, we want to specifically say an application.
Great success with Material Design
This app is Trello
With this app
No matter how big the project is, you can easily track it
If you are working with a large team
And you think that a lengthy email conversation
This app will be very useful if the old version of the spreadsheet doesn’t meet your needs.
So in the process of improving the Android app
Trello takes Material Design as the mainstay of investment
Moreover, their mobile field leaders have said
Focusing on the pursuit of simplicity is a major focus of the use of Material Design.
Material Design is not only beautiful
It did create extraordinary results for Trello.
You can see that the number of sessions per user per week has increased by 10%.
The number of bulletin boards created in each user session has increased by 42%
In each session
The number of users who added bulletin boards increased by 63%.
We believe that the reason for such outstanding results is due to the redesign of Material Design.
Simplified tasks in the app
Make features easier to discover
The user said that the interface has become more interesting.
At the same time, it also has a greater appeal to users.
Last year, many developers told us
Material Design looks really interesting, cool and practical
But do you know?
I will need to get more resources.
To make it easier to use Material Design
Complete the design work
We heard everyone’s voice.
Also fully understand
So we have adopted these new resources listed on the left this year.
I will introduce these resources one by one today.
In addition, we have also expanded the specifications of Material Design.
To add a new set of cool widgets, layouts, etc.
That is the one listed on the right
It is highly recommended that you go online to view these contents.
If you haven't visited design.google.com yet
Please take the time to see
This is Google’s first dedicated to provide
Website with information about all aspects of home design
You can see it on this website.
Everything I said today
Here you can see what's new in Material Design.
Get detailed guides and even find sample code
We hope that the designer's work can be made easier
It takes a lot of time to generate icons in the past.
And now, we are about to provide a huge new resource library.
It contains a variety of icons optimized for Material Design.
This is a great starting point for creating your own app.
There is also a benefit to using the icon of this new repository.
That is, users may have seen these icons in other apps.
This makes it easier for users to discover your app.
We also heard many developers say
They hope to learn more
For all kinds of Android devices on the market
Design specifications provided
With this new device tool
Everyone can learn a lot of information that has not been known before.
Even including Material Design guides for various device recommendations
Now I want to come last year, I heard the most people’s request is
If Google can provide a lot
Reusable Material Design component repository
That would be great
In this way, each development team is building an application.
You don’t have to do it again and again
Make the same material from scratch
We totally agree with this
We don't want anyone here.
Wasting time to create the same content
So we created these new support repositories
It’s easy to use these libraries with the Android Studio SDK administrator.
We will introduce this tool later.
If you want to see these support resources in the library
All backwards compatible with older devices
Or new or old style
Can access google.com/design/spec
This site will provide relevant screenshot tips and more details.
If you are looking for a comprehensive overview of Material Design and a way to get started easily
Take a look at what we offer on Udacity.
New course called "Developer-specific Android Design"
This course will be introduced to you step by step.
Everything you need to know about Material Design
Let you learn how to write code efficiently
Create beautiful layouts
Play the most effective use of Material Design
Ok, we’ve talked about the design.
Next, we continue to discuss the development aspects.
Needless to say, this year’s heavy news is that Android Marshmallow has come out.
It is very cute
Very flattering
It feels very warm
This latest Android version
Also brought major changes to developers
Today I want to highlight some of the two most important changes.
The first is a new runtime permission mode
The second change is
Some new features that help users save battery power
Next, let's talk about permissions
If you want to use any of the Android Marshmallow APIs
For example API 23 then you have to convert your app
Use this new runtime permission mode instead
Runtime permissions are great patterns
Because it gives users more control
Own private information
In fact, at last year's Playtime EMEA conference
Someone has already asked us this request.
This mode is also very practical for developers.
Because it helps to improve your app’s
Installation rate and update rate
Everyone has the Android version currently in use.
Have you seen this process?
When the user installs the app
User must accept all permission requirements
The requirements shown on the second screen
May make some users discouraged
It's like a huge obstacle, right?
This is what the user sees on Lollipop.
On the second screen, you can see
The user has to agree to accept all the requirements
If any of them
Information they do not want to disclose
Then the only thing they can do is cancel the installation.
Then, look for other apps that don't have this permission requirement.
I think you don’t want to see this result.
In the Marshmallow version
We didn't force this scary dialog to be displayed.
So that users can install the app directly
When the user installs the app
No need to agree to any permission requirements
When the user launches the app for the first time
Have access to the required permissions
And the app will only show them the appropriate tips.
They can choose whether or not to accept
This is the first time the user runs the app.
The picture you see
This is the display effect of the prompt window.
Next, everyone should think of it
Users may click "Allow" or "Reject"
There is an important detail to note here.
That is, when the system first asks for permission
Users may click "Reject", right?
This situation may happen
This may happen because
The user does not understand the request or the user may just have a general glance
Did not read the contents of the screen carefully
When the user first rejects the permission request
It’s no big deal for everyone.
In this situation
You can request permission requests later through the app.
If the user clicks "Reject" on the dialog box for the second time
This dialog will appear
You can see the "Do not ask again" option above.
At this time, you should pay more attention to it.
Because if the user has selected this checkbox
The system will not display the prompt again
In this way, if they later
Changed the idea to enable the corresponding permission request
You need to go to the "Settings" section to do the appropriate action.
It is important to say that setting the following
Use all users of Android Marshmallow
You can go to the Settings page to enable or disable
Permissions for any app on the Marshmallow device
These apps even include not yet updated to
New runtime permission mode application
If the user executes one of the unupdated apps
And disabled a permission
Then they will see a warning message
But after that, your app may
Unexpected health
This may be confusing to the user
So to ensure your app
In an orderly and predictable way
Running on a Marshmallow device
We strongly recommend that you as soon as possible
Convert to runtime permission mode
There is another benefit to doing this.
In the past, have you ever encountered this situation?
Is when you add a new permission to your app.
Increase in update rate
It’s not as smooth as it used to be
Of course, we are aware of this problem.
So decided in the new runtime permissions mode
Let the user run at runtime
One by one to agree to each permission request
In this case, these updates will continue to proceed smoothly.
Without any hindrance
Now let's talk
When you switch to the new permission mode
How should we treat the user experience?
You will see users experiencing these issues
But the way to solve the problem is also good or bad.
When the user understands why the system is asking for these permissions
They are likely to agree to the permission request
Next, we will gradually introduce four different methods.
You can use these methods to more smoothly include permission request hints in your app.
In order to meet user expectations
The first method is
Some applications will provide tutorials at the beginning.
Introduce the main functions of the application
You can use this link as a good entry point.
And provide information about why an important authorization is requested here.
Thus
When you request these permissions in the later sections of the tutorial
Users don't feel particularly surprised
Because they know a little about your application.
Although they have not used it before
If your app makes an intentional request
For example, the SMS app will request SMS permission.
Just when the user first runs the app
Just prompt them and you will be fine.
However, this approach is more risky
Because if you feel that the intention is clear
And users don’t think that the result is that your SMS app can’t
Sending a text message is too bad.
Therefore, you must make sure that the user is very clear about what is going on.
Otherwise, consider using the tutorial.
This is when the user first launches the app.
Example of requesting permission requirements
But in most cases, the app is only
Some authorization is required when a user uses a particular feature
Now let's discuss this situation.
When a user first uses a feature that requires permission
for example
Request to use a microphone to record a utterance
Then the best is in the user
Prompt the user when performing the operation, not before the user performs the action
This way you don’t have to go to users who don’t plan to add voice notes.
Show this dialog
There is also no need to request users to grant microphone access
But if they plan to use this feature
Then you can request authorization when they perform the appropriate action
So the user is very clear about what is going on.
In other cases
You must first provide the user with details
Let them know more about how a feature works
Ask them permission again
In this example
We have detailed the use of this feature.
Then, the user can choose to try this feature or refuse to use it.
If they decide to give it a try
The system will get the relevant background knowledge of the function after the user
Prompt to request permission
Even if you think you are clear
Reason for requesting specific permissions
And at the appropriate time to request permission, the user may still refuse
if so
It’s best to clearly explain to the user within the app.
Why some parts of the app may not work properly
Then provide a link to "Settings"
So that they can enable the permissions
In this case the application will use Material Design Snackbar
Show link at bottom
This is a good suggestion
In addition, this is also an excellent time
To reconsider using Android Intent
Is it a way to better solve this problem?
In many cases, you can use Intent
To replace the permissions, this is a more considerate user.
In general
The above is the runtime permission process for the application to use Android Marshmallow.
All the benefits
Next, let’s talk about it.
Some of my favorite Marshmallow features
These features help extend your battery life
I believe everyone knows this is very important.
As a developer, you have to make sure your application
Can be used perfectly with these new features
First, let’s talk about the low power consumption mode.
For example, you will have your own phone or tablet
In the living room
No power connected
Then you go to sleep
The next morning, when you return to the living room
You will want your phone or tablet to still be fully powered
Instead of having no electricity
Marshmallow can do this for you.
Because Marshmallow can detect
Whether the device has basically entered the idle state
Basically, your device is like snoring
When your app is in low power mode
These features are limited
At some point, actually
The entire device is still in use
But only one of your apps is not in use
In this case, all applications that are not in use
Will enter standby mode
This means that these apps save battery
These are used by Android to determine
Whether the corresponding application is in an inactive state
When an app is in standby mode
These features will be affected
Basically, as a developer
The most important thing you have to do is
Use ADB to execute certain commands
In order to be able to simulate these conditions on the device
And test to see if your app still works as expected
If you really need to communicate some messages
And the situation is more urgent
We also offer a special DCM API
With this API, you can send high priority messages
Everyone here must give it a try.
Let's talk about Android Studio
Is anyone using Studio in the room?
Some people have used it, great!
Next, let's take a look
Some recently released features
right here
We launched Android Studio in 2013.
This is basically the official IDE of Google.
If you are still using Eclipse
Please note
We will completely eliminate it before the end of this year.
So, consider this migration at this time.
These are the new features that have been released recently.
Most applications don't require C++ code
But some applications that require a high CPU
Such as game engines, signal processing and physical simulation applications
You need to use this type of code.
If your app does have any of the special needs listed above
You will be happy to hear about a message that is with Android Studio
You can be assured in one project
Use both C++ code and Java code
Users like to run fast on their devices
Strong adaptive ability
And applications that don’t waste resources
Android Studio provides three types of tools
Can help you show extraordinary results in this area
First, you can visually show resource usage in your app.
Second, you can discover the data structure of wasted resources.
Finally, you can understand
The burden of your app on the user’s data plan
And pinpoint exactly where to reduce traffic consumption
The core of the Android strategy is
Our unified building system
We have recently made significant improvements to the performance of this system.
If you want to create an interface in an intuitive way
We have provided some new tools
You can use these tools to drag and drop components
And manage your resources more effectively
Earlier, we mentioned Android Studio
Can assist you with Material Design
At this time, it is best to use the design support library.
You only need to use Android Studio
Will be cool Material Design widgets
Drag and drop to your app
And they will be backward compatible with Android 2.2
In addition to the Android design library
We also offer a range of other libraries
You can access and learn more about these libraries online.
These libraries are very helpful in speeding up the development process.
Finally, Android Studio
It also makes it easy to port your app to a new device type.
You can quickly create a brand new Android Wear theme
Even simulating the Android Auto app
Finally, let’s talk about how to
Users distribute apps and how to build your business
The main function of Google Play is
Let your app reach users who really need it
In addition, we have provided some great tools.
To help you improve the quality of your app.
However, I want to tell you some good news first.
The current file size limit for APK is 50MB, right?
The upper limit is 50MB
Whose application size is close to 50MB?
Maybe close to 50MB, 49MB?
If anyone wants to install an app with a file size larger than 50MB
The system will display this warning, right?
Someone saw this warning after
Feel a little worried, so click "Back"
Or, you have to spend some time
To set the APK extension file
Share a good news with you here.
Google will announce today that the file size limit will be increased to 100MB.
We are also very happy
This time we have been working hard to prepare for this.
Carry out a lot of testing
Because we have to confirm this change
Can work with a variety of equipment and operators
But we hope that everyone is the first to know this news.
We will announce this news in a blog later today.
We just want to remind one thing
Even though we increase the APK file size limit to 100MB
But users still like smaller APK files
Please do not let the file size exceed 50MB when all is not necessary.
Now let’s talk about it in detail.
How to use iterations on Google Play to test new ideas
We offer a complete set of specialized tools
Mark also mentioned these tools before, these tools can help you get feedback early in development.
We recommend every developer
Take these best practices
Our best and most successful developer
Are using these tools
If you haven't used these tools yet
Then you will definitely miss it
A great opportunity to build high quality applications
Is anyone using the Beta test?
Great, I’m so happy to see so many people raising their hands.
This is a very special feature on Google Play.
You can distribute your app to a small number of users.
And get feedback early
Lest after a full release
Pray again, don't go wrong
With beta testing users can choose to join the test
But they can’t leave a review, it’s very cool
If you haven’t used it then you must try it.
Developers tell us that beta testing is a great feature
But we want to find out more ways
Make it easy for users to join in
So this year, we announced two changes.
The first change is the open beta test
If you need it, you can actually
Distribute a link to your open beta test
Users simply click on the link
You can go to a similar page and add it to the test.
It’s that simple
Users can join the test rank with a single click
Developers can come this way
Develop a large beta test community
Of course, you can still choose
Create a dedicated closed beta test
However, now you can still
Create this type of test with the email address option
We launched this option early this year.
Let’s take a look at why the Guardian will tell us
They are big fans of beta testing
In the past six months
Almost every function of them has been tested after beta test.
Will be released
On average, they need to improve three versions before each official release.
They said that this feature is indeed
Help them speed up development
Tested by Beta
They can safely try out new ideas without risking the brand.
In addition, it also helped them collect some data
Enabling them to provide this data to stakeholders
To help them make tough decisions
In the past, it took them a month to release new features.
It’s now less than two weeks.
Alternatively, you can also post it in stages
Make sure your app doesn’t post any errors to new users
Basically you just have to launch your new version.
But not for all users
But for a certain percentage of users
You can continue to increase this percentage over time
At this year's Google I/O conference
We announced the upcoming launch of Cloud Test Lab
We are currently testing it with a small group of developers.
If everyone is interested
Can access the Developer Console to apply for participation in the test
I hope we can add you to this beta test soon.
Google Play wants to do a mission with the Cloud Test Lab
That is what we intend to apply to all Alpha and Beta apps.
Send to a batch of physical devices for testing
You will get the test results soon.
For those who haven’t tested Alpha and Beta yet.
This is another good reason to try this feature.
It can help you detect any major problems
We heard some developers who tried the old version said
The first reaction after they finished the test was
I feel this feature is great.
However, I want to write some very specific test scripts.
On this particular device that is difficult for me to track
carry out testing
So we also intend to provide you with such a function.
Via Android Studio
You can write custom test scripts
Then run on a virtual or physical device
Especially for the devices you want to use.
This is all we have said today.
First of all, we hope that everyone
Create great apps and grow your business with Google Play
In the design phase, benefit from massive new resources
Material Design may be more than ever
Easier to use
Android Marshmallow during the development phase
Bringing some major changes to developers
Such as permissions and low power mode
Android Studio and other resources
Can assist you with testing
Make sure you build high quality apps
Finally, distribute quality apps
Easier than ever because Play offers a variety of development center tools
Helps you refine and test your new app over and over again
thank you all
[play music]